اشير الى هذا الخبر وهو بحسب القناه
الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه التي قالت ان تصاعد
الكلفه الباهظه للحرب دفعت رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو لدراسه اغلاق بعض المكاتب
الحكوميه وتحويل اموالها لتغطيه تكاليف
الحرب دون دفع ثمن سياسي لذلك وبينما اوصت
وزاره الماليه باغلاق عشر وزارات يرجح ان
ان يقدم نتنياهو مقترحات اخرى اقل رمزيه
من من ناحيه اقتصادي اعود اليك الان سيد
جبارين بالحديث عن نتنياهو نفسه بنفس
الملف هل يتلاعب نتنياهو بالجميع ام فقد
السيطره على
الجميع يعني لكي نعو في السياق الذي ذكرته
قبل قليل وربما هنا يمكن الربط ما بين ذلك
وما بين يعني كيف يتلاعب بنيمين نتنياهو
في الموقف بنيامين نتنياهو بالاضافه انه
عمل على اخطاب كفاءه المستوى السياسي في
داخل اسرائيل في العقدين الاخيرين فقط لكي
لا يكون هنالك في داخل المشهد من هو يتفوق
عليه سياسيا بالاضافه الى ذلك هو عمل على
نوع من الفائض الوزاري في داخل اسرائيل
احيانا وصلت عدد الوزارات الى اكثر من 30
وزاره
بم
لديه يعني لكي يعطي الكل ويوزع الكعكه بين
جميع اعضاء ائتلافه الحكومي اغلبيه هذه
الوزاره اما وزراء في داخل مكتب رئيس
الحكومه اما وزراء في داخل وزاره الدفاع
موتش على سبيل المثال اما وزراء بدون
ملف كذلك الامر يعني في نهايه المطاف
هنالك فائض من الوزارات الذي تم توزيعه
وهنا المطب الاكبر بالنسبه لبنم تنيو هذا
الفائض كان يخدمه سياسيا الان هو بحاجه
لان يتخلى على ما وفق ما اشارت يعني وزاره
الماليه على الاقل على 10 وزارات اي
بكلمات اخرى هو بحاجه لكي يثير غضب ع
شخصيات سياسيه بالاضافه الى الغضب الموجود
اليه في داخل الكابينت يعني ليس فقط في
داخل الكابينت بل كذلك ائتلافي وهنا هو في
موجود في مطب حقيقي واما ان
يغضب الصهيونيه الدينيه و بينفي بمفهوم
كذا او كاخر واما ان يغضب الحريديم واما
ان يغضب وهنا النقطه والمطب الاكبر
الليكود الليكود كان يدفع الثمن الكبير
والنفيس فقط لكي يغلق كل هذه الملفات
بنيامين نتنياهو امام الشركاء الاخرون
فبالتالي الان اذا اراد ان يغلق عشر
وزارات بمفهوم كذا او كاخر لديه عشر
شخصيات التي يتوجب عليه ان يثير غضبها وفي
ظل كل تراكميه المشهد في ظل الحديث عن
لجنه رسميه للتحقيق في ظل الحديث عن ضعف
بنيامين نتنياهو واضح جدا ان هذا يعيدنا
الى معادله مهمه جدا ان الحكومات في
اسرائيل تنتحر ولا تقل بمفهوم اخر ان هذا
بات نهايه هذه الحكومه بات وشيكا اكثر
بكثير مما كان عليه في الايام السابقه
اشكرك ايهاب جبارين الباحث المخصص بالشر
الاسرائيلي حدثنا مباشره